What is the greatest contribution of your country to the entire world?
I feel like the contribution is just that we have a wonderful influence on the world,...
...and we can always help other countries if they need our help.
And we can give back as much as we can.
I'm born and raised in Amsterdam, and Amsterdam is one of the most tolerant cities of the world.
A lot of art and history and I'm very proud of it, thank you.
So now, we have a very difficult situation in our country.
And right now the very most important contribution...
...is to direct all of our energies to support our army and our people.
As we all know, we have the home to the legendary Usain Bolt, Bob Marley,...
...who have contributed such great music to this world,...
...and we have the fastest man alive who has been trailblazing the Jamaican flag.
Thank you so much.
I believe that my country has been an example to be followed by the rest of the countries.
We are persevering people no matter what obstacle we have in our way,...
...and we continue fighting for that which we want to accomplish...
...notwithstanding many difficulties we have gone through.
Today, we are world leaders in many different matters.
And I am quite proud to represent it before all of you.